[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro du café politique
sur tv fil 78 revue de presse de
l'actualité de ces quinze derniers jours
en compagnie des élus du département et
pour m'accompagner au cours de cette
prochaine demi heure françois simeoni
élu fn d'opposition à versailles vous
êtes aussi le président du fn dans le
département comme le créateur
départementale le centre est grandement
bonjour c est la responsable
départementale également mais du parti
socialiste dans département donc des
yvelines et vous êtes aussi élus de la
majorité à trappes et nicolas danville
bonjour à vous ai vu l et r d'opposition
à la verrière est élu à saint quentin en
yvelines on va commencer par ces
policiers en colère on en a déjà parlé
ici dans ce café politique mais les
tensions avec les forces de l'ordre ne
retourne pas le mouvement est né à la
marge des syndicats habituel mouvement
spontané après le drame de
viry-châtillon françois simeoni je
voudrais qu'on commence ou même avec
vous parce que le meneur de ce mouvement
fin tout cas celui qui s'était improvisé
comme le meneur de ce mouvement de
grogne n'est visiblement pas policier on
dit aussi proches du front national
c'est le point.fr qui avait fait ses ses
révélations si on peut dire
est ce qu'une récupération politique ou
est ce que c'est un mouvement qui est
initié par le fonds national très
clairement écoutez je pense que c'est
seulement prêtés sont ces mouvements de
ce mouvement est né spontanément chez
les policiers comment voulez-vous client
soit autrement avec ce qui se passe
lorsque les mulets les policiers sont
attaqués à la chez eux dans la rue et
fille n'ont pas le droit de se défendre
non c'est un mouvement spontané bien
évidemment nous front national nous
avons toujours soutenu les forces de
l'ordre et principalement ces mamans
difficile et on peut pas parler de
récupération politique
les événements sont politiques
effectivement vous fait pas de la
récupération sans rien en jambes on voit
bien qu'il ya à la fois un mouvement
spontané qui est de fait récupérer mais
ça c'est la loi du genre et en même
temps
une réaction là du gouvernement qui
marque zain a reçu les syndicats à
discuter ceux qui sont sortis il a aussi
reçu d'ailleurs un porte parole
autoproclamé mais qui correspond aussi à
un malaise réel et puis et puis le
président la république
reçoit aussi mercredi
les syndicats pensent qu'à une vraie
écoute qui est un vrai malaise que on a
une caste l2 des forces de police dans
ce lit notamment avec le suppressions
postes sous le quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy que maintenant il faut remonter
la pente et il faut mettre les moyens et
françois hollande est en poste depuis de
cinq ans on m'a aidé à recruter et
recruté également à recruter énormément
il y avait eu 13 me en bas du corps et
des commissariats qui sont insalubres
des choses qui n'ont pas été rénovés
qu'il faut continuer à mettre les moyens
financiers aussi et donc mettre le
personnel et tous ceux qui l'ont
expliqué par exemple que la solution
miracle s'était par exemple les caméras
on voit bien que la solution c'est
d'abord des présences de présence
humaine et des gens équipés sur le
terrain mais quand la norville m'écouter
il ya un vrai ras-le-bol comme on l'a
dit ras-le-bol sur les moyens
je pense aux moyens humains mais aussi
aux moyens matériels on le voit avec des
voitures qui sont totalement délabré du
matériel qui n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux il ya un policier qui me disait
qu aujourd'hui il avait l'impression de
vivre une ruine delà de la police je
pense qu'il est aussi un ras-le-bol face
à cette certaine culture de l'excusé
en dézinguant mais il ya certains
politiques de gauche qui ont l'habitude
de voir les délinquants comme dédé comme
des enfants monsieur 15,9 parler de
sauvageons alors que c'étaient des
criminels en bande organisée donc je
pense qu'il faut avoir le courage de
mettre les les bons mots malek boutih à
gauche samia ghali également eu le
courage d'une certaine manière de mettre
les mots justes en disant qu'il fallait
lutter avec une police anti racaille
pour neutraliser ceux qui pourrissent la
vie dans les quartiers je pense qu'il ya
aussi un ras-le-bol sur le laxisme de la
justice ils l'ont exprimé qui a été
aggravée par la politique mais mme
taubira on a eu l'arrêt de construction
de places de prison les remises de peine
aux nouvelles un ciel qui faute sur le
beau porter la faute sur le gouvernement
en quelque sortie je vous écoute on
attendait sandrine grand gant de dire
c'est nicolas sarkozy qui a commencé je
pense que là sur les chiffres de mam
révoqué par madame grand nombre il faut
prendre la pl la période totale où
nicolas sarkozy était aux
responsabilités donc entre 2002 et 2011
il ya eu des effectifs à peu près stable
il ya une suppression effectivement un
certain nombre de suppressions de postes
à partir de 2007 avec la rgpp mais il ya
eu une forte augmentation à partir de
2002 pour combler les suppressions de
postes dues aux 35 heures il ya eu 8000
à peu près suppressions de postes avec
les 35 heures donc il juste pour
terminer le cas à la fois ce ras-le-bol
moyens culture de l'excusé laxisme de la
justice aggravée par madame taubira
laxisme également avec cette culture
anti flics qu'on a vu notamment lors des
manifestations contre la loi travail la
fiche de la cgt qui était absolument
scandaleuses ont aidé des crs sur les
flaques de sang qui alimentent cette
haine du flic qui est vraiment très
difficile à comprendre pour les
policiers qui sont sur le terrain et
pour terminer je dirai que aussi une
attente sur l'amour une réponse
judiciaire apporter une réponse
législative ils attendent notamment que
la loi de la légitime défense soient
harmonisées entre celle des gendarmes et
des policiers aujourd'hui n'ont pas les
mêmes conditions d'ouverture du feu et
donc c'est un vrai problème dans l'état
d'urgence et face aux nouvelles menaces
partagez cet avis simulation est
question de la légitime défense d'abord
sur les chiffres effectivement un grand
gang disait qu' il ya eu soit sarkozy
treize mille postes de prestige en armes
sont prévues
c'est exact et d'ailleurs nous l'avions
dénoncé à l'époque on était dans
l'essonne et françois hollande n'a pas
rétabli le compte puisqu'il ya eu des
créations je crois à peu près 4000
postes seulement donc ça qu'on pensait
absolument pas la perte et pour ce qui
est des problèmes liés à la justice
effectivement il ya un certain laxisme
chez les juges mais qui n'est pas
généralisable je pense que ce qui manque
surtout dans la justice c'est une prime
de moyens un moyen de gestion des
dossiers et moyens aussi des au niveau
des places de prison parce que on ne
peut pas demander à un juge de faire des
condamnations qui ne serait pas suivi
d'effet donc c'est essentiellement un
problème de moyens et bien évidemment
nous vous savez ce qu'on propose bien
sûr redonner les moyens en terme
d'effectif et aussi en termes de places
de prison en commençant par expulser
tous les tous les condamnés
donc il est haut qui n'ont pas leur
place avec les gens qu'on souhaite
vous avez aussi la tête
on parle évidemment tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire il faut plus d'homme
ou de femme il faut plus de moyens puis
quand on regarde les programmes derrière
qui vaille un problème en adéquation
entre ce qui est proposé notamment sur
les voies dans la primaire de la droite
où tous les candidats explique qu'il va
falloir supprimer un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires et par un petit nombre et
puis le discours et puis faire des
économies etc et on voit derrière que
les moyens on en a besoin sur la justice
effectivement il ya nécessité de
continuer à mettre le paquet sur la
justice partie des actionnaires puisque
le disclose les juges laxistes et sert à
avancer ça va un petit peu un petit peu
pénible d'entendre toujours cette
rengaine qui correspond pas une réalité
la réalité beaucoup plus complexe le
monde de la justice est très divers
christiane taubira a fait un excellent
travail je ne sais pas partager ici mais
moi je soutiens la politique qu'elle a
menée et et je pense qu'effectivement il
faut mettre des moyens financiers
notamment aussi sur la déchire mais à
vendre il faut être cohérent dans ce
conte juste par rapport à la fonction
publique aujourd'hui et pour ouvrir un
peu le discussion il ya un vrai
ras-le-bol de la fonction publique dans
son ensemble aussi en ce qui concerne
les enseignants par exemple on pourrait
parler de ces enseignants aussi qu'ils
sont pris à partie dans les classes
aussi la ministre vallaud belkacem qui
les incite aussi à déposer plainte dès
qu'il ya la moindre agression vous êtes
aussi enseignante d'ailleurs et françois
chaignaud ni aussi et j'en ai quand même
avoir votre sentiment sur cette
profession aujourd'hui des enseignants
qui est non seulement a du mal à faire
son travail mais qui en plus est est
aussi quelquefois prise à partie il ya
aussi des violences qui les touchent
c'est vrai crois qu'il faut pas
généraliser il ya dans
99% des cas on arrive tout à fait bien
faire notre travail et on le fait avec
passion mais mais derrière il ya
effectivement ces cas là encore
inacceptable de collègues qui ont pu
être agressée il ya eu des
établissements qui sont donc mais on
voit bien là aussi que toutes ces
questions sont liées c'est à dire que
on a supprimé par exemple le palier de
la période des années 2000 ont supprimé
la police de proximité qu'il y avait un
vrai rôle dans les quartiers ça c'est
une erreur à mon avis qui est donc on
paye encore les fruits aujourd'hui et
après sur la profession d'enseignant
c'est la question de l'autorité qui est
posée en fait dans ce pays de manière
plus large et l'autorité à se décrète
pas de manière
il autorise des halles est liée à la
compétence elle est liée aussi quand on
voit un président de la république qui
attaqua % d'opinions favorables on a du
mal à se dire qu'il est l'autorité aussi
est-ce que ça va
non ça mais parce qu'on parlait aussi du
gouvernement et du rôle de gouvernement
d'impulser d'avoir un certain un certain
respect d'imposer le respect en dari la
question du respect de l'autorité ces
deux notions qui vont ensemble et qui
touche l'ensemble de notre société et le
monde politique aussi donc tout le monde
politique doit s'interroger sur comment
on regagne en forme de crédibilité aussi
de respect d'autorité qui
incarne l'exemple puisque nous devons
porter avant de demander aux autres
partis de la composante des composantes
de la société d'être exemplaire aussi
d'un village ou ferait réagir aussi sur
les enseignants parce que comme je le
disais vous êtes aussi enseignant aux
civils effectivement pour rebondir sur
les policiers là c'est une manifestation
a ras-le-bol qui est assez inédit je
crois que les dernières manifestations
de ce type c'est remonter en 1958 à
l'époque on avait général de gaulle ce
qui n'est malheureusement pas le cas
aujourd'hui sur la crise d'autorité
aller profonde née elle s'exprime après
les les violences faites envers les
forces de l'ordre envers les enseignants
je pense que mai 68 a une philosophie
qui a remis en cause un certain nombre
d'autorités de hiérarchie d'ordre de
respect je pense que ça fait beaucoup de
dégâts aujourd'hui dans le monde
enseignant je pense que les enseignants
doivent être mieux respectés par les
élèves et un certain nombre
d'initiatives privées qui pourraient
être source d'inspiration pour
l'éducation nationale d'aujourd'hui je
pense notamment aux écoles de la
fondation séance banlieue notamment à
montfermeil je sais pas si vous la
connaissez le court alexandre dumas avec
vraiment le val à mettre l'accent sur
les fondamentaux le respect de
l'enseignant qui est un véritable maître
comme les hussards noirs de la
république l'était auparavant et il ya
vraiment la notion de réussite de
l'esprit d'appartenance à la nation et
je pense que c'est des valeurs qu'il
faut
enseigner et transmettre encore plus
aujourd'hui ça sinon je vais te plaire
au niveau du front national dont des
fonds dans la fonction publique dans le
cas d'un état stratège et notamment ses
fonctions régaliennes comme l'éducation
ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui n'est que
le résultat de ce qui a été initié
depuis de 30 ans à peu près
et les problèmes principaux étant la
dévalorisation du métier la
massification de l'enseignement général
ce qui fait que la fonction a été
attaqué dans son essence on ne voit plus
effectivement de personnes qui qui
souhaite redevenir enseignants les
enseignants il y en a un sur trois dans
le secondaire qui envisagent de changer
de métier donc sa jambe on lit ce que
vous aviez dit tout à l'heure je pense
qu'il ya un mal être réelle chez les
enseignants et ça fait trente ans que je
suis dans l'éducation nationale donc je
le
le constate aujourd'hui de faire mal
être ça leur vous disiez dans 99% des
cas les choses se passent bien et on
peut enseigner correctement quelle est
la réalité aujourd'hui du corps
enseignant
je pose la question à tous les deux mais
simplement pas la minute 15,8 des
réalités peut-être différent dans un
établissement qui
aucune difficulté à signer jeu réagir
juste après france à saint denis près
terminée on nommait encore sur un
positionnement va qui nous conduit à
nous traiter de réactionnaire je pense
que quand l'action est négative la
réaction est positive et actuellement on
constate que le système est en
déliquescence complète donc le seul
moyen c'est une parole remettre l'enfant
ou si l'on est au centre du système
éducatif ça c'est une erreur principe ça
c'est de remettre le savoir au centre du
système éducatif de revenir sur les
fondamentaux
au niveau de l'enseignement et notamment
l'enseignement primaire et de valoriser
aussi l'enseignement professionnel
apprentissage qui n'a jamais été fait je
rappelle que jean pierre chevènement
était parti sur l'idée noble a priori de
80 % d'une classe d'âge au niveau au
niveau quinté niveau bac etc en fait cet
objectif devait être suivie avec une peu
prise en compte de l'enseignement
professionnel du bac professionnel qui
n'a jamais été suivies pourquoi parce
qu'il est beaucoup plus simple et
beaucoup plus économique d'ouvrir des
classes d'enseignement général ce qui a
été fait que des classes d'enseignement
professionnel ce qui fait
qu'actuellement sur le à peu près 75 %
de la classe d'âge qui est bien le le
bas qui arrive au niveau bac vous avez
seulement 10% qui correspond au bac
professionnel donc les objectifs en
termes de bacula professionnels n'ont
pas été suivies pour rebondir sur les
moyens qui évoquait madame brand gambien
une étude que vous avez dû suivre donc
celle du cne sco qui montre que l'école
malgré les moyens malgré les soi-disant
60000 prof supplément l'objectif n'est
pas encore atteint aggrave les
inégalités scolaires avec un impact
social qui est encore plus important
aujourd'hui qu'il n'était il ya donc
rétablir l'autorité que ce soit envers
de forces de l'ordre ont regardé
enseignants c'est fondamental je
continue un petit peu cette revue de
presse et on va rester sur le domaine
des enseignants parce qu'il ya eu cette
actualité locale
lorànt deutsch comédien auteur aussi
devait intervenir dans une école à la
trappe pour pour présenter un spectacle
faire une intervention autour du
festival histoire de lire ça a suscité
la colère de deux enseignants qui ont vu
ce de se détacher de cette participation
est finalement le comédien a annulé sa
venue vous êtes élu à trappes vous
condamnez vous comprenez l'attitude des
enseignants mais je pense qu'ils ont
joué un rôle essentiel d'alert dire
qu'en fait c'étaient ces quelques heures
dans la même situation vous auriez
refusé également d'être associés et que
lorànt deutsch vient de faire son
spectacle dans le jeu qu'il vient de
faire son spectacle c'est j'ai fait
celui fait ce qu'il veut la question est
là il s'agissait en fait des trois
collèges de trappes donc c'était une
intervention de scolaire présenté comme
une leçon d'histoire
fait par lorànt deutsch
moi j'ai rien contre lorànt deutsch mais
pour moi il à prendre par les astres qui
il a droit mais qu'on me dise pas que
mais elles doivent aller écouter ses
cours d'histoire à lui parce que je
considère qu'il n'a pas à se repaître du
divertissement etc mais ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui est qui a à savoir on
parlait tout à l'heure de la nécessité
de remettre le savoir au coeur de de
l'enseignement là en l'occurrence c'est
quelqu'un qui est capable de dire des
contrevérités et d'avoir une approche de
l'histoire très problématique donc ma
came en donner des collègues disent nous
on ne souhaite pas parce qu'au départ il
était
il y avait cette idée que c'était
obligatoire donc ils sont intervenus en
disant nous nous considérons que
comprendre pourquoi ce serait
obligatoire et donc nous ne voulons pas
que nos nos élèves participent à sa
ensuite il ya eu donc à une alerte qui a
été fait au niveau notamment du rectorat
et il ya la décision de qui a été prise
de diodes premièrement évidemment ce
n'est pas obligatoire et donc libre à
chaque enseignant d'y aller ou pas et
finalement il ya eu d'admiration
vous partagez pas du tout ce point de
vue nicolas bézy la maison vous avez
s'est même fait un communiqué pour
pisser condamné l'attitude des
enseignants il s'est passé la même chose
à mantes-la-jolie l'année dernière où là
c'était un prof d'histoire donc monsieur
qu'elle sadiki qui était venu à
mantes-la-jolie s'exprimait devant des
élèves il y avait eu la même réaction
d'enseignants d'une petite partie du
monde enseignant qu'il faut dire les
choses est une militants là les deux
enseignants dont on parle sont des
militants du front de gauche donc je
pense que c'est pas une question de
pureté académique mais vraiment une
question idéologique il supporte pas
qu'on ait une autre vision de l'histoire
que avant il y avait le monopole du
coeur il ya le monopole de la culture
maintenant ils veulent avoir le monopole
c'est
juste pour terminer pour moi c'est
vraiment bizarre ils sont sûr j'ai déjà
lu lorànt deutsch et rouky je comprends
bien ce talent de transmettre cette
action de l'histoire de france et des
millions de français je pense que comme
le fait par exemple monsieur berne dans
l'histoire dans à la télévision c'est
pas des historiens ce sont des passeurs
justement il éveille la curiosité
historique à des jeunes qui sont souvent
éloignés de ce savoir donc c'est très et
c'est vraiment très important et pour
terminer il ya une phrase moi qui
m'avait particulièrement choqué c'est la
justification de ces deux enseignants
ils disent notre rôle c'est pas de faire
aimer l'histoire de france n'est pas
terminée la france pour être précis mais
je pense que l'histoire de france ça
doit pas uniquement de rendre honteux
par rapport à notre passé doit également
nous rendre fiers et de vision très
opposée françois simeoni vos sites fléau
moi je pense que
l'école est un sanctuaire c'est que
finalement les gens qui peuvent y
exposer doivent être des personnes
qu'ils soient spécialistes de leurs
matières donc je suis en quelque sorte
un petit peu d'accord avec madame mais
maintenant le problème c'est que notre
jeu notre métier a été dévoyé et d'une
part on a des interventions extra
scolaires en nombre très important qui
sont imposées par notre administration
concernant des positionnements pour
lesquelles je pense que madame g serait
très favorable notamment relatifs à
l'éducation
démocratiques et républicaines la
théorie du genre d tout un tas de
le point qui peuvent sembler être de
l'endoctrinement d'une part et donc là
pas de réaction de la part de ma
collègue sur sur ce point là et d'autres
seraient donc encore réagi mais sinon
interne et généralise effectivement et
donc pour ce qui est de monsieur deutsch
effectivement le problème c'est que les
programmes d'histoire actuellement ne
font pas une l'histoire donc pourquoi
pas envisager la présence de quelqu'un
qui est là pour ramener un petit peu le
goût à la matière est effectivement le
fait de ne présenter les programmes
d'histoire très très structurant que
comme un fonctionnement un enseignement
par ten et s'est fait passé complètement
l'histoire de france sous la trappe et
de manière générale l'histoire des les
nations les hommes politiques d'
importantes sont complètement passés à
la trappe donc je pense qu'effectivement
les enfants perdre le pain de le goût de
l'histoire et à la limite si
l'intervention se dote peut rattraper un
petit peu le coup après après a priori
lorànt deutsch n'est pas historien mais
bhl n'est pas non plus philosophe donc
voilà c'est ça peut être que le
considérer comme quelque chose de
positif bien que je suis encore
favorable au respect de l'école d'antan
que d'accentuer les recettes sont
actuellement sont également non mais
c'est
il ya une forme de déjà de mépris aussi
vis-à-vis des trappistes c'est pas un
hasard c'est dans le discours qu'on
entend c'est les petits trappistes ils
savent pas aimer l'histoire de france
enfin
insupportable c'est pendant cette heure
c'est mieux car c'était aussi ça qui
était qui était derrière donc moi je
trouve ça absolument insupportable on a
des élèves dans les écoles de tra qui
aiment la france qui aime l'histoire de
france il y en a qui aiment pas parce
qu'ils aient moins l'histoire et on est
là pour leur apprendre les fondamentaux
et quand vous disiez sur des
interventions qui peuvent un taux de la
démocratie de la république a oui moi je
suis d'accord pour qu'ils aient de
l'intervention sur la démocratie
république c'est notre rôle que je joue
bien mais correct mais je pensais
dévoiement de ses interventions
notamment pour y faire passer des
messages comme la théorie du genre etc
les fantasmes qui existent mais
l'égalité fait les gagne pas énorme et
l'égalité filles garçons c'est aussi une
réalité et quand je chante en votre
vision de l'histoire c'est une vision
pour moi effectivement que je respecte
quand vous avez cette vision de
l'histoire de france mais complètement
passive l'histoire a été faite par
quelques hommes en fait la vie de femme
bien sûr ce que l'état n'existe pas dans
l'histoire c'est bien connu donc oui en
effet
bah oui mais justement regarder ce qui
vous avez cités vous avez cité que des
hommes et donc je pense qu'un ont donné
il faut aussi être capable de vous faire
comprendre que la france est une nation
c'est c'est la république qui s'est
construite difficilement mais c'est
aussi une nation avec des hommes des
femmes qui ont construit cette nation je
pourrais donc que je marque mais je sais
pas c'est parce que jamais
vous savez très bien continuer une secte
and dark et elle figure utilisé
notamment par la gauche donc c'est une
figure qui qui a été là aussi parfois
des voiliers en ce sens mais qui ne me
pose aucun point on a beaucoup parlé de
ces représentations de figures
historiques de vision ce qui fait qu'on
a pris un peu de retard sur les missions
et c'est déjà le moment de faire un
petit tour de table de de conclusion
qu'elle l'événement vous garder en
mémoire sur l'actualité des quinze
derniers jours en ce qui vous concerne
alors moi je vais sortir un jeu pas d'un
événement un peu personnel qui va
particulièrement choqué marqué c'est la
proposition de benoît hamon de légaliser
le cannabis alors on le voit dans
beaucoup de quartiers c'est un drame
pour beaucoup de familles avec des
enfants et des lunettes chez psion est
leur préciser exactement avec des
enfants qui qui décrochent qui ont des
pertes des troubles de la mémoire de la
concentration à cause du cannabis et je
trouve que c'est un message de laxisme
assez terrifiant envoyé aux dealers et
autres trafiquants on baisse les bras on
légalise et au lieu de lutter contre ce
trafic qui fait beaucoup de ravages dans
nos familles donc sa main quelque chose
qui m'a particulièrement marqué sans les
imagine que vous avez répondu
à trappes aussi le message envoyé aux
dealers c'est justement de dire vous
n'avez plus votre place dans les
quartiers et donc on est dans le tout
répressif la sueur sur le cannabis je
pense qu'il est temps d'imaginer autre
chose il ya beaucoup d'études qui
montrent qu'il ya peut-être d'autres
solutions mais puisque vous citez benoît
hamon moi je continue dans l'actualité
il ya je pense qu on est dans la période
des primaires
les trébéens à droite les primaires à
gauche et il ya une proposition qui est
en train d'émerger qui est discuté à
droite et à gauche ailleurs que benoît
hamon porte qui est le revenu universel
et au moins il ya cet intérêt des
primaires delà des affrontements de
personnes que de faire monter des sujets
aux débats après on se positionne et je
pense que le revenu universel est un bon
sujet aujourd'hui de débat et qui mais
nécessitent que l'on s'y intéresse avec
beaucoup d'intérêt en tout cas moi je
suis très favorable à cette réflexion et
cette procédure soit simeoni je saurai
mais j'espère que vous n'allez pas me
parler je
vais quand même vous parlez du revenu dû
verser aux normes universelles proposé
par benoît hamon c'est 700 soit 750
euros pour tout le monde perd peu à peu
près 2
un smig descendu et
dévalorisant complètement la fonction
travail des gens vont rester à toucher
cette somme dérisoire chez franchement
senti sans même parler du financement
mais mais non moi ce qui m'a bien sûr
toucher et motivés c'étaient c'est la
ventilation des des migrants du
dukan de calais sûr qu'elle ait tous les
maires sens et sont en train de réagir
et de refuser
de recevoir ces ces migrants et on voit
tous les élus aient l'air notamment de
l'ouest parisien qui sont favorables à
l'accueil des millions de contradiction
totale avec la population je rappelle
que tous les élus européens tous les
députés européens aient l'air et ps ont
voté pour la répartition des migrants
donc les maires de ces communes l'un
d'eux
on ne peut pas comprendre ces décisions
prises par leur politique donc bien sûr
nous on s'oppose à ça et on fera tout ce
qu'il faut pour réagir et montrer qu' il
ya une autre vie à dos il existe une
autre solution et la concertation dans
le département se poursuit puisque le
préfet reçoit régulièrement les élus
pour évoquer ces questions de de
répartition d'accueil des migrants et
des réfugiés aussi parce qu'il faut
aussi évoquer les jours optimum avec les
élus un peu d'humanité dans un monde de
brutes ça fait un peu de bien aussi
quand même ne parlons pas d'humanité et
de ce terme encore de ce travail
sémantique qui est fait
c'est le terme de réfugiés moi je suis
utilisé les deux termes c'est pour ça
que j'ai dit aux réfugiés en fonction du
point de vue où on se positionnait bien
je suis moi j'avais pas je vais défendre
les enfants et des femmes je madame
ouvrant banque je vais vous citer les
l'étude qui a été fait par une ong qui
s'appelle droits des réfugiés refugee
rights une ong britannique qui dans son
étude incité qui avait 94 % d'hommes
seuls 73 % de personnes de moins de 25
ans et un pour cent seulement que c'est
rien et 0 6% d'irakiens donc quand on a
40% dessous d'année 20% d'erythréens et
20% de d'afghans on ne peut pas parler
de réfugiés on ne peut pas parler de
famille ou à la limite envisager des
familles monoparentales sans enfant
constitué exclusivement d'hommes là
effectivement je m'arrêterai là du tout
d'accord en deux mots très rapidement
non monsieur je pense qu'à un moment
donné il ya des réalités humaines qu'il
faut prendre en compte l'état est là
pour gérer aussi sûrs et liquides même
et pour trouver une solution merci à
tous les trois on va s'arrêter là on a
déjà bien déborder sur l'émission
c'était le trente cinquième numéro du
café politique on se retrouve bientôt
ici toujours au bistrot du théâtre à
montigny
[Musique]
à